ich finde aber ist reichlich absurd die
debatten die da aus der union gerade
kommen also ernsthaft zu erzählen man
habe einen auftrag zu regieren nachdem
man acht prozentpunkte verloren hat oder
noch mehr nachdem man historische
unbeliebtheit werte hat nachdem man
wirklich alles falsch gemacht hat was
man in einem wahlkampf falsch machen
kann die dreistigkeit zu haben jetzt
davon zu sprechen man habe ja einen
regierungsauftrag könne irgendwie so
weitermachen wie vor ist ja gar nichts
passiert warum denn dann machen wir halt
jamaika dann ist die angela merkel weg
aber ich ziehe dann ins kanzleramt ein
und wird alles ganz gemütlich das finde
ich absurd und ich kann das immer auch
noch nicht so richtig glauben dass da
niemand in der union mal aufsteht und
sagt moment mal hallo aufwachen hallo
armin aufwachen wir haben acht
prozentpunkte verloren und dass man sich
jetzt da hinstellt und sagt ja wir
wollen jetzt da in die regierung ich
kann es mir so richtig vorstellen wie
armin laschet im konrad adenauer haus
sitzt und die ganze zeit auf seinem
handy hin und her tipp mit christian
lindner und sagt na ja mit uns ist schon
viel schöner und besser und dann
passiert auch nichts schlimmes also der
wird alles dahin werfen damit er dieser
chor kommen ich finde ja wir brauchen
eine debatte auch mal darüber was
eigentlich bei der union passiert ist
und offenbar in der union selbst wie man
die nicht führen jetzt haben wir ja ganz
vergessen unseren vierten gast hier zu
begrüßen deswegen guten abend an einen
handy was sagt das denn gerade werden im
hintergrund wirklich jetzt dran die
messer gehört es ist schon ein bisschen
kaputt
gemacht in diesem jahr hat einige mp
karte durchgemacht also was nicht höre
ist dass in der spd ziemliche
ungläubigkeit darüber herrscht wiederum
was die grünen angeht dort ist man etwas
verstört über die aussagen von robert
habeck man hätte sich gewünscht dass der
sich viel klarer äußert was man außerdem
hört aus der spd dass man davon ausgeht
dass die grünen sich jetzt zerfleischen
könnten in dieser nacht das da die
großen messer fliegen denn es soll eine
art dir gegeben haben zwischen robert
habeck und annalena baerbock dass wenn
das ergebnis unter 15 prozent fehlt das
dann obert habe die fäden übernimmt was
man aus der fdp hört in diesen minuten
in diesen stunden ist dass christian
lindner und wolfgang kubicki erst mal
wein trinken wollen in ordnung so haben
wolltest gesehen das war die karte aber
der wirt wolfgang kubicki nicht lange
bleiben da wird man sich zusammensetzen
und dann versucht man im engsten kreis
dort etwas festzulegen und tatsächlich
wollen fdp und grüne das erste unter
sich ausmachen und das ist ja spannend
offenbar versuchen die gerade eine
koalition der kanzlerschaft zu formen
warum der kanzlerschaft weil sie
zusammen so mächtig sind dass sie den
kanzler bestimmen können wenn du das
hörst wenn du jetzt fast zu hause sitzen
die wählerinnen und wähler haben ihr
kreuzchen gemacht in berlin teilweise zu
wirklich widrigen umständen wie wir
gerade gehört haben den ganzen tag über
und dann sitzt man da ist bis
mitternacht und wie weiß man überhaupt
gar nicht wieder vater geht in diesem
land man hat überhaupt keine ahnung
irgendwo werden messer gewetzt und
andere sachen positionen hin und her was
geht dir durch den kopf der deutsche
2017 leidgeprüft im koalitions finden
also fast schlimmer als 217 wurde nie
die große em die jamaika-koalition dann
geplatzt ist damals hat christel inder
ja gesagt lieber nicht regieren als
falsch zurück gehen deswegen ist
natürlich jetzt die koalitionsbildung
extrem spannend claus strunz hat ja
heute mehrfach über die groko gesprochen
das ist ja auch noch eine möglichkeit
wäre das glaub ich jetzt nicht aber ich
habe ja noch
mal ganz klipp sagen möchte wo ich heute
ganz lange darüber nachgedacht habe als
ich immer wir diese wahlergebnisse
gesamtjahr moment mal eine sache ist
doch jetzt komplett klar wenn er dateien
wo es ergebnis haben will stellen den
kanzler dann gibt es tree elz der
kanzlerkandidat krieg extrem viel
aufmerksamkeit ich finde das
wahlergebnis häufig weiß die union wurde
abgestraft aber ich habe mich schon
heute abend öfter gefragt wie wäre es
denn gewesen wenn christa länder als
vierter kanzlerkandidat da gewesen zwar
wollen trotzdem man kann trotzdem mal
darüber schauen
ich finde das ist mein trotzdem das ist
schön dass wir beide sagen nein
lass nach vorn schauen und ich glaube
schwanz möchte ich hab heute bei phoenix
gesehen statistik die fand ich spannend
und zwar hat armin laschet doppelt so
viele schmähungen im social netz
bekommen die armierungen wie scholz &
berger gemeinsam und da muss man schon
sagen es war ja auch ein großer medien
wahlkampf ich bin jetzt man was die zeit
bringt ich finde es gar nicht so absurd
dass laschet auch noch probleme
koalition zu finden lässt sie aber
leidgeprüft sind wir nach 2017 ich hoffe
es geht schnell
[Musik]